today the city of Henderson kicks off
their Juneteenth celebrations with a
flag-raising ceremony it's this
afternoon at City Hall from 2 to 3 P.M
the city is also celebrating Juneteenth
with a three-day cultural festival and
that begins on June 16th at Water Street
Plaza there'll be live African-American
musical performances dancing and other
Arts it's all in partnership with the
national Juneteenth observance
observance Foundation of Nevada Nate
well Sherry speaking of Juneteenth on
this Saturday you can celebrate with the
cookout this is going to be at the
Cambridge rec center from 4 until 7 in
the afternoon food games arts and crafts
they're even doing free haircuts and
stylings you're looking for Juneteenth
events we've got them all check out our
website 8newsnow.com